[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
what's going on guys
no it's not Starfield you know I'm
surprised some of you didn't notice what
it was it's uh some of you did it's out
of Worlds I love that game I love that
theme song I think theme song is very
well done
uh so I wanted to put that on for you
guys because uh that song has definitely
been nice to me man
got the Gucci glasses on no I definitely
don't have Gucci glasses
uh let me turn this down a little bit I
still want to play a little bit in the
background
at first I was like
am I gonna put that in there it's like
Microsoft and
you know obsidian gonna come after me
like is this is this is this a wrap for
me like is is this over
[Music]
Starfield music will be even better I
bet I hope so
uh so we are waiting for dirt uh dirt
had some family stuff he will be coming
I'm waiting for Forte's well uh Fort
Forte gaming Forte will be here as well
uh so you know there's a lot of stuff
going on right now we got stuff to talk
about we got stuff talk about
obviously I'm probably not going to be
like energetic like I normally am you
know I'm going through a breakup right
now
so don't expect that energetic thing for
me because I don't know if I can produce
it today like look addict is who I am
but I you know I gotta I gotta get some
I gotta give him some
uh but you know we we're gonna we're
gonna get stuff yes hold the line I
cannot believe
King with that crazy foolish hold the
line thing because now people are
tagging me and say hold the line at it
hold the line I'm not holding nothing
okay
stop it stop it don't it's just break up
he's not only want to play it you ruin
that
no Zachary you can't say nothing hold
the line addict
no Kings General King says we gotta hold
the line we gotta hold the line
that's how that that's the rules don't
be mad at me be mad at the person who
made the rules
I don't wanna
know sad stuff in the chat stop it
you know we we we I'm gonna be fine
I'm gonna be fine so it's okay no sad
stuff only reason I'm telling you is
because like if I'm a little off today I
wanted you guys to understand why I'm a
little off
we gotta make addict Hold the Line how
you gonna make me do anything
see the the monitors are over here
and the cameras over here
so it's hard for me to like
keep up with the chat and
do that that's a little bit better
but then I feel like
I gotta be
that's good
one went to the Showcase uh we
definitely got some stuff to talk about
when it comes to the Showcase
um let me look at the because our shows
are on Wednesdays we'll do we'll do the
we'll do the thing on the 25th I think
that's the day let me look dirt is on
his way it's 24th dirt is on his way
guys it will be okay Dirk will be here
eventually
I'm looking right now I'm still waiting
for Forte look I I plan on doing the
show by myself but I but you know
dirt's showing up and so is forte so we
good this is the pre-show all right this
is the pre-show
I bet she was a terrible and that was
like no
yo
stop it that actually made me laugh that
was funny that was funny
nah there's just things you know when it
comes to me and Grace I was uh the name
of the woman I was dating I you know she
she just got a lot of stuff she's gotta
take care of you know
[Music]
I will say that mental health is
extremely important and I want I wish
the best to her
you know sometimes I go through it
really bad I'm going through it right
now but I'll be good
Kraken them then podcast
go get the rebound attic nah I'm good
man I'm good you know what's funny is I
I try to like
I felt like maybe if I downloaded like a
dating app or something it would help me
like like keep my mind off and stuff I
couldn't do it man had to delete them
not ready for that not ready so I'm
gonna I'm gonna jump into some content
that's what I'm gonna do I'm gonna jump
into content and uh you know that's a
good way of keeping myself busy is that
what comes out Friday
see you know imma do that you know I'm
gonna be on that Zelda
you know I probably should you know go
get my my hair cut and stuff
yeah money over women right there only
on Xbox money over women now I didn't
you know uh I would I would I would have
picked my ex-girlfriend over money but
you know I here's the thing
yes she broke up with me obviously uh it
was a little bit of a mutual thing but
at the same time it's one of those
things where it's like
there was clearly issues in the
relationship and continuously attacking
the situation until she handles stuff on
her end that she feels like she needs to
handle I gotta respect that and I gotta
step back and let her handle that now
obviously things might circle around but
that's up in the air uh no one is
guaranteed a future and right now I'm
not focused on anything about that
relationship I'm focusing on bettering
myself as an individual that's what I'm
focused on
before we know you won't be on Xbox
uh look man
Xbox being rough man I'm I'm J I'm I
know Xbox being rough
zero could always be there for you
addict you know what's funny uh
astrocross it's a uh it's a destiny
YouTuber he has like if he gets like 65
000 subscribers or something like that
his wife is gonna let him name their
daughter Zelda and I think that was
funny that's good man that's good
so you know we we got the Phil Spencer
interview to talk about let me make sure
that they can come in just fine
all right so I disabled the waiting room
I don't think Dolan was in the waiting
room
Let Me Go full screen
so
so I'm waiting for them to come in here
we got some Phil Spencer interview stuff
you know just going over General quotes
we didn't talk about it because it was
after the podcast last week now we did
talk about on IOP and I generally try to
keep what we talk about on this show
different from IOP but there are certain
things that I can't avoid I have to talk
about and you know while waiting for
those people I'm going to tell you I
have to talk about that you know EU is a
is a new development happen today
uh two dollars from John TJ uh hi Adam I
think the deal will go through I hope so
too man you know it just depends we
don't know what's going to happen on
here we don't know uh the conditions
that's gonna go happen you know I'll get
more into that when we talk about the
actual topic and Starfield actually got
rating
um they actually are going to have a lot
of stuff coming up and I think we're
gonna have a really nice show especially
next month we're gonna have a good
showcase and I'm excited for it man you
know shout out to the 187 people in here
uh we are waiting for our two guests you
know we're a little bit behind today I
apologize for that we're doing kind of
the pre-atic show right now so
definitely hit that like button if you
guys don't mind you know hit that hit
that like button it's 29. I want that
like like 50. can 50b thing can we do 50
I think we can do 50. you guys stop
fronting with me and get that to 50.
God Delaware said with the one man show
yeah one man show look
solo podcasting is one of the hardest
things that you will do because you
don't have someone to bounce back off of
but throughout the years I've gotten
really comfortable at doing the solo
podcasting thing but the only reason I'm
able to do it effectively is because I
got you guys
to to bounce off of you know I don't got
a physical person to talk to right now
because Forte is God knows where and
dirt's on his way home but I got the
chat to bounce off of and that's all I
need is that chat
I might hit up a pawn shop and get a
switch yeah
um all right all right hold up hold up
guys put in that chat right now
three intervals you guys know how it is
what's Zelda
tears of the Kingdom going to get all
Metacritic Friday or tomorrow I don't
know when yeah tomorrow tomorrow what's
out again I'm saying a 95 94 9-5 that's
what I'm saying
94.95 93 that's my three 93
94 and 95.
oh snap let's go 50 likes you guys love
that I'm joking I appreciate you guys
you know I wasn't gonna do today's show
my dirt was busy doing stuff and you
know I'm definitely not 100 here
mentally to do this uh but I was like I
need I need some distractions I need to
get out of my head
so I was like you know what let's go on
here let's let's talk let's give on a
show let's do what we came here for
and I appreciate you guys coming through
man I appreciate you guys coming through
we got 201 people in the in the chat we
got 55 likes man we doing this we got a
lot of 96's 97s 98's you know uh does
anyone in the chat think this is going
to get below a 90 like an 89 it would be
interesting if this guy below 90. I
don't think that's possible
to be honest with you but it would be
interesting nonetheless if it got
below a 90.
um see but here's the thing I think that
doesn't matter if the game
gets below 90 sometimes the game still
doesn't do well
foreign
slave don't trip addict love ain't
nothing but two people feeling sorry for
each other and it's got some point to
that you know one thing that you know I
I did promise myself after this
relationship as I take my health more
seriously I feel like sitting at this
desk you know if not doing uh the side
stuff that IOP does or doing shorts or
doing my own videos or doing the three
podcasts a week I do I do feel like I
was letting my health Decline and that
was one of the things that we went back
and forth with and that's you know she
was she's not she was not a bad woman
she did everything she was supposed to
It's just sometimes when you're not
mentally uh mentally healthy it's hard
to really commit to anything and we
agreed that that's something that she
needs to work on and I need to work on
my my health I do yeah sometimes I'll
sit in this chair for 10 15 hours some
days you know doing shorts for YouTube
uh doing thumbnails for other people uh
doing editing for my own channel you
know I got to do better on that man
today I walked like three and a half
miles and so God will be one of those
things I gotta be bad better for me I
can't do it for another person doesn't
matter I gotta be better for me and
that's what I'm going to work about
look at no Bunty talk about games please
man we just started we we've been
talking about games this whole time look
at these man you talk about real stuff
even a little bit people just go crazy I
get it you guys sub to these to for game
conversations I feel you man I feel you
uh so I'm kind of curious where these
people are at this point you know dirt I
kind of expected him to be a little late
because uh he's driving home but let's
call Forte live let's call Forte live on
the show
yeah you think he's gonna pick up guys
think he's gonna pick up
he's probably watching so he won't pick
up
nah it doesn't look like
hey hey we we right now in the show uh
where you at
this is all right man just I sent you
the link whenever you're ready just join
okay all right man peace
all right
um
no that's not it can you hear me dirt
yeah
all right let me make sure yeah we good
dirt dirt's in the house so we can start
the show
and uh I was waiting uh but we are
eventually going to have uh Forte show
up in here
yeah I got
hey can you hear me yeah
I got one slide problem what what's
wrong I'm gonna have to leave at 6 30 on
the dot bro oh no it's fine dude
whatever you got to leave you got a lot
of important stuff going on yeah I got a
lot of crazy stuff going on today head
out the back door man don't even say
nothing be like I'll see you next week
wait all right so let's get into this
man because we don't got you for long
and you know obviously we gotta break
these things down so the first thing I
want to talk about
let me get this ready for the time step
Mafia uh because you know how they'd be
you know I'm usually I have the
timestamp mafia stuff on on this side
step Mafia but
I'm not ex it's like I said guys you got
to be patient with me yeah uh I'm not a
hundred percent
right now uh where am I
got to get this I got to get the time
okay the time so we about what we're
going to start Starfield 19 minutes so
star Phil no 20 minutes
star filled
dirt uh we we got a rating we got a
rating and I did you think this game
wasn't going to be rated in because
let's let's ask that first
I thought it was going to be ready now
yes yeah because I think these days we
kind of expected this to be rated in
but the way that the industry Rose when
a game is rated T doesn't surprise me
yeah because I feel like they're so used
to just putting stuff out there as a t t
for team or they love that e the E for
everyone I hate that one it's something
for everyone everyone man I'm scratching
my head like is it is it is it really
everyone or is it not for me because
that's not everyone you know if everyone
can't play the game it's not for
everyone sometimes I I do feel like
Microsoft has got away from having
mature rated games and
um you know what do you feel about that
do you think that they I do think that
they didn't really say that uh there was
going to be any
like
like romantic relations in the game so
it's kind of weird that there's like
sexual relations but not romantic does
that make sense like
like you just be doing prostitutes
that's the only thing I could think of
like hey man they said they're gonna
have um
uh drug Labs right so maybe it's drug
you can't do drugs
I'm saying I mean I don't know but I'm
I'm excited for it man uh some like
sometimes as adults we need a
a mature rated game once in a while you
know we mature
we'll mature man I like games with
swearing in it violence I mean listen I
am a grown man I'm 46 years old I love
R-rated movies you know I do like pz13
movies also but if only if the only
movies we had was PG that would kind of
suck as an adult that's why I like I
know Forte isn't here yet or is like
Donna Taco in the chat I haven't looked
that's why I'm not a huge Nintendo fan
at this point
like anyone could pick them up and play
them
yeah but sometimes you know I I want to
grant their father I want a Gears of War
I wanna Last of Us you know that's just
me so to see that Starfield which is a
huge game that's going to be mature yeah
that's what we want man all right so
let's get these super chats real quick
for uh
final subscribers from Nintendo uh
Nintendo Dom do otaku I can't wait for
another six years of people crying about
how overrated Zelda is the most
delicious tears out there
um I'm hearing good things about Zelda
I'm hearing good things a couple people
I don't have the game I'm hearing really
good things
um I expect like a 95 uh anywhere 93 to
96 that's where I'm expecting uh five
dollar super trap from uh D beanie
gaming probably butcher that we're gonna
move right past that Dreamcast uh
Dreamcast guys video about Starfield was
terrible today about the
microtransactions the reason I really
talk about the microtransactions because
I don't really know what they mean by
microtransactions
um I don't want my stuff for you yeah
apparently there's microtransactions in
it how do you feel about that what
to me
that can be no big deal and it could be
the big deal at the same time like there
could be a lot of bad scenarios uh that
happen with that well I always said this
even years ago when I had 100 Subs on
YouTube I never had a problem with
microtransactions as long as they're
Fair
just be fair don't be paid to win is
there a fair they're they're optional
they're not a huge part of the gameplay
you know they're just some optional
cosmetic stuff cool I mean however if if
Starfield has microtransactions as long
as they're fair I have no problem with
it I always use an um an analogy when it
comes to microtransactions yes you have
a pizza you can get regular cheese and
pepperoni right
which is fine but if you want a little
you know some extra toppings
this extra money
that's not I mean that's just my opinion
I think to me the reason I'm not for
this and it's not like you're for it
like you you I think at this I'm not
missing before you just got to the point
where it's like look it's gonna happen
as long as it's not intrusive they're
not going anywhere not sure I I think
the the thing I don't like about it just
depends how it does it's like you said
like if it's one of those scenarios
where they're like look
here's Starfield
um if you want to maybe buy certain uh
stuff from other companies like make
your character look different ways like
Minecraft then here's your options to do
that but I don't want them hiding stuff
behind a paywall and where you have like
anything that can be accommodating
besides maybe you know maybe skins from
other games like making yourself look
like Naruto or something like that
besides that if it's in the game I want
it to be available in the game I don't
want you to sell me a gun that you can't
find in the game like if if you want to
go and take that shortcut in buying it
that's one thing but if you if you make
me get the microtransactions to get that
gun that's when I usually draw the line
when it comes to stuff like that
yeah I understand
um I just feel at this point it is what
it is you know these microtransactions
aren't going anywhere
they're going to be a part of the gaming
industry moving forward so I think some
people might not like it
like I don't know if you remember macho
man he said you might not like it but
you gotta accept it someone did make a
good point maybe it's microtransactions
for the creation Club maybe they're
going to be more open to you buying
stuff would that be fine uh so look when
it comes to something like that okay if
if someone else takes the time to make
something and they want to be
compensated for it then I have no
problem giving them money for that if
it's something that I seriously take a
value then that's fine you can monitor
I'm all about creators being able to
monetize their their their work and if
it's that then that's fine uh and if
it's something like small that's fine
but to me what if it comes like a game
like Starfield there's less stuff I'm
more I'm gonna be okay with than a game
like OverWatch or a Call of Duty because
I feel like there's way more
opportunities to monetize in those other
games and there is something like
Starfield uh there's very few times I'm
going to say something in Starfield and
think it's okay but I'll see that same
practice being used in OverWatch and I
think okay you know this makes sense but
when you talk about single player games
you're trying to like sprinkle some some
some micro transactions that's when I'm
a little side eyeing yeah man I'm sorry
I mean yeah I understand what you're
saying but I'm just kind of like yeah
they're not going anywhere I mean
every game is going to try to somehow
like like for the most part it's going
to try to somehow
um sprinkle some micro transactions
yeah especially these expensive AAA
games like the Starfield I see you guys
talking about Dreamcast sky in the chat
look you guys can have a disagreement on
what he said but it's like and I totally
understand if you guys don't watch it
it's like just don't bring that to my
chat like it's like go tell him you
don't like his videos like it's like
yeah this thing to chat this ain't the
chat for that guy yeah you could say
that in the chat I ain't gonna like
silence you or anything to me
we know that there are people out there
that are very I don't think Dreamcast
guys makes videos that he doesn't
believe in like he I don't think he does
any like form of clout chasing I think
he just adds spice to everything he does
because he knows it generates extra
traffic
yeah yeah
so
let's let's get on with the mess
let's get on with it let's talk about
the Xbox deal with the EU so we about 28
minutes into the podcast
X the the EU the E and the U is rumored
that they're going to accept the uh the
ABK though uh but I wanna first off I
want to put out a little disclaimer yes
please
Dart we heard these same rumors about
the CW yes put out that disclaimer
please we heard this same thing uh
but like that question was asked to many
people this morning but they were saying
the difference is
um publication like Bloomberg or Rector
is it is it is it Rutgers they didn't
say that with the CMA I don't know but
I'm just kind of like this I'm going to
wait
until it's official before I start
talking trash anything like that it's
one of those things where it's like yeah
at this point the avk deal look we got
to talk about it from time to time
because like we are uh you know content
creators we're making content but at the
same time it's like we gotta pull back
on some of these things I see people
acting like just because this happened
it's a wrap it's going through now no
it's not even at the EU the the EU does
approve this I will say it's gonna look
better but at the same time they still
got that c uh the CNA right that's their
name right I so many abbreviations CMA a
CMA uh CMA FTC the EU they still got
some some stuff to cover even if this
gets approved
yeah I agree
um but I will say this if the EU blocks
it I think the deal is officially uh
done bro officially
yeah so you know I think I'm right there
with you I'm like look at the end of the
day
we just need to
do a better job at keeping our
expectations because here's the thing
like as as content creators and stuff
and people we know we got to realize to
some degree that we're going if what we
say
is going to influence other people so
for instance you know this 330 people in
this chat you know if me and Dirk came
in here and we'd like dirt I think this
deal is going to get past oh my god
there ain't nothing gonna stop it If We
Hold the Line
oh the line
[Laughter]
yeah I feel like that's going to
influence a lot of other people and
that's why you're seeing like this like
kind of little Echo chamber going on in
the community where it's like everyone
thinks something because a couple
influencers like really push the fact
this is gonna get pushed like to me if
you do that you do that but to me
this deal can easily not go through and
it can easily go through we don't know
what's going to happen at this point
addict I think a lot of us learned our
lesson a few weeks ago
um because listen let's be honest on
Twitter on that Tuesday night
um a lot of people's like yo we're gonna
wake up in the morning and CMA is going
to prove the deal it's going to be
beautiful I saw a couple of YouTubers
already make a thumbnail saying approved
which you know myself I had a thumbnail
on wbg that Monday that said CMA will
approve the deal
yeah no no no no no my yeah yeah pretty
much because my show was on Monday the
deal announcement was Wednesday so yeah
I I did it several other YouTubers did
it and we all look foolish I got so many
comments saying this didn't age well I
said you damn right he didn't I've been
doing a video like every day on the
weekdays like almost every day Monday
through Friday video every day I've been
seeing you you've been doing like good
consistent content yeah and that day
people are like addict you know how many
people hit me up was like addict this is
going through this this is going through
yeah so I had every intentions when I
woke up that day that I'm about to make
a video
on
on that stuff like I was convinced I was
gonna make a video on that particular me
too me too bro and then when I woke up
and people were tagging me people were
dming me the IOP chat was going crazy
he's like oh I'm making another video
today like
yeah I had to make a video I didn't
really want to but yeah so that's the
thing that's why I think a lot of people
are being cautious with this because we
heard some of the same things um now
there seems to be a little bit more for
some reason confidence with the EU but
I'm still like yo man because I would
never forget that Wednesday morning when
I woke up and
I saw Activision Blizzard stock just
died if I was like oh shoot so listen
I'm just like this
I'm going to sit back I mean we can talk
about it we can speculate but as far as
this talking trash no not until it's
official and even if the EU approves it
like you said it's still not 100
finalized it definitely helps the case
for it to be finalized but it's still
not finalized yet so I'm going to lay
low
um like I said if EU does improve the
deal we will talk about it obviously
but we're not going to run yo 100 this
deal will be finalized I'm not going to
say that at this point it's like look
there is updates on this it looks like
there's rumors that it's going to get a
pass in the EU and I think that's gonna
look really well especially if they come
to an agreement with FTC and get that
passed because then at that point
absolutely absolutely being at the
spotlight's gonna go on one organization
absolutely and I think they'll have a
lot better chance at negotiating with
them when everyone else is saying yeah
we good but that one person uh I think
Microsoft will have a lot better chance
with that
we got a 10 super chat from boss red77.
I'm about to change my name to the real
Dreamcast guy because it was it was Sega
that led me to the OG Xbox caught it
near the end of the gin and instantly
fell in love
the OG Xbox man I love that thing bro
it's it's pretty good man five dollar
super shot from drawing TJ
Microsoft could still close the deal and
just pay the fines it's a vertical
merger uh can they do that can they just
pay for I don't know I I do know like a
lot of people were saying if the EU
approved and FTC approves
um XBox at that point they still can do
the merger um just some things will have
to change in in the UK or if you know
you know some stuff like that because
some people talk you know HBO Max is not
available in the UK because of
you know like don't call me on this
because um they didn't approve certain
things with the merger with HBO Max and
whoever else so I don't know we'll see
what happens man
yeah um
here's the thing I I think that there's
definitely some stuff going on in terms
of of what's going on behind closed
doors but I don't think nothing's in
stone I think absolutely not yeah I
agree all this is is politics all of it
you know who can get the most I do feel
like at the beginning
PlayStation was just causing issues
because they wanted a lot of
consolidations and I think when they
started noticing yo
they're caring
they're listening to us and I felt like
that at that point they didn't want
consolidations because even Jim Ryan
came out like to do it I don't I don't
want to have a deal with Call of Duty I
don't I want to block this merger yeah
yeah and part of me feels like
if Sony's being this extra over this
merger over this over this this
acquisition
like how much of their company relies on
Call of Duty
yeah I think yeah I mean he said it he
said if uh Call of Duty goes into Game
Pass
um they can't recovery or Call of Duty
is owned by Xbox they can't recovery and
and the last thing is Jim Ryan said if
Call of Duty is better
on Xbox than it is on Playstation they
can't recover he said that you know
that's why I'm like okay I know we're
going to get to the field spiritual
stuff I might just feel sad some stuff
but
oh Jim Ryan didn't get as much heat for
the things he said regarding
Call of Duty and throwing his first
party teams up under the bus meaning
Call of Duty means everything to
PlayStation he didn't get as much heat
um for saying that then like some of the
things that Phil said you know I'm sure
everybody
I wonder if the money they get from
PlayStation is so essential for what
they do at PlayStation that they're
scared
rotating some of that money to to
Microsoft is going to be if like really
devastating to them and I think yeah we
don't know what Call of Duty is going to
be in 10 years Call of Duty can be
irrelevant I doubt it but and then 10
years it could be again one of the most
profitable games just like it is now and
when these deals start to end up and it
comes to these renegotiating tactics
what's going to look better you go in
there with Call of Duty with the 10
years that's going up are you going
there and there's no 10 years and that's
why I feel like PlayStation knows like
look like this might not affect us right
now but if we can in the long run if we
don't actually hit this out the park and
do what we can to stop this and it don't
matter if we look weak we gotta stop it
and shout out to Jim Ryan he didn't
deserve a raise
because it's just like we sit here
thinking he's making PlayStation look
weak he's making them look like uh the
first person talking about the third uh
third person jealous of the of the third
uh
he's jealous of the third company yeah
right place but you sitting there
looking at that and it's like he that
had nothing to do with it he was just
like
sometimes when you need something done
you have to be very dirty about it uh
two dollars from Tia uh t h x one one
three eight CMA block 10 t uh ATT and WB
merger HBO Max pool from UK that's what
I was trying to explain thank you bro
do you think they would do that though
that's drastic well yeah but well like
that's what HBO Max did because CMA
blocked the A10 T and WB murders or HBO
Max got approve everywhere else to say
fine no HBO Max in UK that's what
happened that's what's going on now
because I talked to my homie Sean who
lives in UK they don't they don't have
HBO Max there I'm wondering if that gets
blocked does that mean all of Xbox
titles can't be there or is it just
um I don't think it'll be all Xbox
titles maybe Game Pass can game be there
or maybe Activision Blizzard games
um can be available for in like for for
Xbox game pass in in the UK now I'm just
talking out it's like the side of my
head I don't know what I'm saying but
I'm just speculating here if this deal
is approved by everybody except for the
CMA
maybe Activision Blizzard games cannot
be will not be allowed to be in Game
Pass
so that's the only thing I can think of
we got gaming for sale first off I like
that backdrop it's a nice little
backdrop
uh I got I got a this IOP Banner that's
all I got you got all these colors looks
like you in a Star Wars movie right now
I got to this 59 rated game behind me
buddy how y'all like that one so what's
going on Forte
homie
oh he's gone he's out
14 but it's been silenced what'd it do
what's going on and there you go it was
coming through my headset and not my mic
yeah sometimes it does that especially
like the Shara mics oh you have a shirt
on Mike yeah these Cheryl mics do that
this arm I hate this arm I need a better
arm because if like you see like right
here like this material is it the
greatest and the material that puts this
arm on it is like curved and not flat so
like if I move this up right now really
fast without holding this part here it's
going to come off the entire desk get
yourself a PSA one you're gonna give me
a link you have to send me a link so I
can click on it and look at it I will
send you a lick all right we we are
talking about the EU being approved we
got until 6 30 before we lose dirt you
gotta go you gotta go straight out the
door he got to do like the A Team where
they jumped out the tank and they were
flying the tank he got to go straight
like straight out after that they're
trying to fly he trying to fly a tank
right now what do you think about the EU
do you think that this gives hope or do
you think this is one of those scenarios
where it's like like where me in dirt or
like look
this is good news in a way because it's
Lisa stop being blocked well rumor too
do you think people need to calm down a
little bit and actually see the
full-blown announcement because like
it's like me and dart was saying before
you came in here these same rumors were
going on about the CNN sure was yeah and
guess what I learned and guess what I
told people then I was like um
tip for your expectations who know like
man until this comes out and they
actually fully say that we approve this
message right
yeah
don't jump off of no Ledges that you
can't that you can't land on
hey hey yo Forte they got so many
receipts on XBox guys including myself
they ain't got no receipts on me because
I said knocks out there is like I was
like all I kept saying is the deal is
going to go through
but until that deal goes through leave
me alone right it's just one of those
things that you know very smart
you know from a perspective especially
people captivating on you know the
console war I'm sure I'm sure dirt over
there foam into the mouth accept it if
you accept it Imma have so much fun like
oh yeah yeah I I do think I mean it is a
it is a it is definitely a positive step
in the right direction it's like
until you actually hear them say that
we're going to support this and we
actually want this deal to go through
you're it's like you're going to be it
you should be especially after with the
CMA the CMA had everybody out here who
Paula and had Xbox fans out here saying
tomorrow's going to be a great day I'll
go to sleep I'm gonna sleep well you
know you know when I wake up in the
morning it's gonna be sunny and it's
going to be real cloudy over there on
the other side of California and Santa
mate you know that's whatever that's
what people were saying yeah yeah I saw
it bro you're right yeah it was crazy
then all of a sudden you know just like
the weather here in Michigan things
changed
yes it's crazy it's the exact opposite
happened the complete opposite you know
it was it it almost seems like you know
uh a certain
uh not uh a certain uh financial
analysis for gaming actually said that
the deal was going to go through and it
didn't and that man is always wrong yeah
every time he says anything he's talking
about Michael Factor yes yes it's like
he he he he got he ghosts us man got us
in trouble but um I do think
um for the most part this is a good this
is good news but I mean really after
anything is kind of good news after the
last two weeks that we had as Xbox fans
honestly that's oh I mean the last month
bro well the last two weeks has been
pretty oh yeah yeah last two weeks have
been pretty bad pretty bad like it it
was it was it was teetering in that
direction it did it was like it was like
that it was like yeah you remember the
first two weeks is like in the war when
they send the scouts and then it's like
they found where we was and I sent the
rest the Army right it's just like it's
like it's like the Remake is like the
remake of the first start of the the new
the the news version of the Star Trek
movies when young Kirk was riding in the
car you know he saw was the cliff coming
that was like a month ago you saw the
cliff coming you did all of a sudden you
forgot that the cl that the car was
going 70 miles an hour and that Cliff's
gonna get here a little bit faster than
you thought right then all of a sudden
the cliff is upon you and that's
basically where we are right now so
let's just hope that you know with this
news that it brings more good news in
the future because let's be for real if
the EU does approve it officially
approves it it did that puts more
pressure on the FTC and then it did now
I did at the FTC Falls in line Dennis
likes CMA you're the only one right
you're the only one of the big three we
got 67 percent of the market basically
saying this is good outside of all the
other little jurisdictions like Brazil
and everything else that approved it
right you're the only one that's holding
this up and like you said at this point
at that point if they wanted to they
could push the deal through it just have
like you know a bunch of different sages
where it doesn't really happen over in
that uh part of the world but I do think
it puts more pressure on that but baby
steps at this point you know that's
that's kind of just look at it as like
this is positive news but don't Bank on
it right yeah so when you get we can't
bake on it
not until it's official bro the only
thing you can bake on is Nintendo making
a fire game that's gonna be Game of the
Year at the end of the year that's the
only thing you can bake on for the year
2023 baby
I know it was coming the deep inside
dirt he is not filling that statement I
knew it was coming what's happening Hey
listen man tomorrow's going be a big day
midnight launch whoa it's gonna be a big
day nice all right so you get that final
Super Chat from rain because uh yeah I
get it
#tts hashtag wbg ILP dirt looks like
he's about to do an unclassified Mission
shout out to attic and Forte he rang G4
how dare you sir you're gonna see his
dirt take off like he's gonna take his
glasses off his throat and they're gonna
explode
I'm gonna need you to read I'm gonna
need you to redo that Super Chat and add
hashtag DPS to that sir there you go yes
we missed it up in there man we're gonna
have to get you you and um slow motion
that was a fun time when we had you
answer that actually did very well
people really liked that podcast it's
got a Slumbers combative and I am too
and then I don't take nothing from him
got a 20 subscribe from drawing TJ if
the EU passes it Microsoft will just
close the deal and take FTC to federal
court because the FTC doesn't have a
case and CMA messed up because Amazon
Luna is now in the UK and they have 12
million subscribers compared to Xboxes
that is that is true so I heard that we
only got dirt for like another another
15-10 minutes we're gonna go to this
game
he's got some real life stuff going on
so I got some stuff we we we got to go
into this Phil Spencer for those who
didn't know we missed it because I think
it was Thursday of last week yeah it was
yep
so
on kind of funny Phil Spencer went on
there and he had a couple statements you
know first thing I want to really talk
about is the big statement that people
talk about is him saying that you know
just making good games isn't going to
deliver them to like win a console
generation quote unquote uh so let's
start with dirt you know you don't have
to just talk about that talk about
anything that you want to talk about
because of the Phil Spencer but let's
start with that particular statement
well when he said that I took that like
this
um
when okay for example
a great game is important we all know
that exclusives are important great
games are definitely important but
um sometimes
having the Casual box
might outweigh having great exclusive
titles let me explain
um the Nintendo GameCube had great
exclusives
people only care about the PS2 because
they were buying all of the multi-plus
the big multi-plats on the PS2 the same
thing with the N64 same thing with the
original Xbox you know these games are
great
um they they mean a lot but I think what
Phil was trying to say nobody is going
to all of a sudden if you're a
PlayStation fan you're not going to all
of a sudden
stop playing PlayStation
leave the ecosystem and go to the Xbox
ecosystem because you want to play
Starfield and Starfield is a great game
now those guys will will maybe buy start
from their PC they might even buy a
console just to play Starfield but they
wouldn't probably not switch ecosystems
I am an Xbox fan but I do have a PS5 I
like the PS5 I play some of their
exclusives but after I'm done with those
exclusives I'll go right back to the
Xbox so I think he meant ecosystems
nobody's going to become a Xbox Fanboy
immediately because of a good game I
mean some people disagree this is just
how I took what he said
um you know that's just my opinion
okay so Forte obviously
you know there's a lot what I don't like
about this is it was so open of a
statement you could literally take this
a couple different ways I'll give my uh
because I want you and dart to talk more
because we only have Dart for like
another 10 minutes follow Super Chat
from Iron Mike uh Lotto Hypocrites
turning a blind eye to low rest textures
pop in 15 FPS frames and paying 70 on
Friday Nostalgia is a hell of a drug
he's talking about redfall
I might get a pissed off Forte man
he's looking for that medicine to help
him calm down he's like
what listen
I have a drawer at my job
field of stuff that's from Zelda that
comes out on Friday that I'm picking up
on the same day trust me I do not want
to spend 70 bucks on the game this game
I don't want to spend 70 bucks on a game
that's going to probably run at 24
frames per second at most on the
platform that I'm gonna play it on tears
of the frame rate I I don't wanna Iron
Man like I think you got him on the
ropes listen I don't want to do that I
don't want to do that you got a tuck and
roll you got a tuck and roll but just
like just like I play a busted piece of
crap of a game back in November last
year when Halo when Halo infinite came
out okay
wasn't broken no no
it was okay not busted
incomplete yeah you're right incomplete
I played an incomplete game knowing that
I told myself I am not going to play
this game because this game should not
have come out right now it should have
came out a year later why are we playing
something that's incomplete
I still played that game reluctantly
have fun with it but the thing for me is
if I'm a fan of something I don't care
what it is there's there's there's only
three major franchises in the whole
world that I will drop everything for
biases and everything go out so so
what's the three what's the three we got
Zelda obviously you're gonna pay Seven
for 15 frames okay what's the next one
Zelda Halo Halo okay okay in Mass Effect
Mass Effect something we ain't really
seen in years and Halo
it's something that was yeah my three my
three loves it sounds like you're
holding on to hopes and dreams well I
already know what did you see the
announcement that uh dungeons are
definitely confirmed for um tears of the
Kingdom I got to see the dungeons
because technically the shrines could
have been considered dungeons no no
nobody I'm sure I'm sure if you talk to
someone on the dev team they would have
said they consider the shrines the new
the new age dungeons I'm never gonna
tell anybody that you should now you
should you should clown people like me
that's up here I don't take personality
man at least yeah I don't I don't take
it personal with people
you sitting up here talking about this
game and you up you know you're also
saying how red flaw runs like garbage
and nobody should play it I didn't say
nobody should play grateful I'm just
saying have better standards if you got
a system that you bought that cost six
five hundred dollars and the the the
promise was to be able to play your
games at a higher frame rate that you
should hold them to that standard now
let's not be let's not like act like
that when Nintendo came out with that
switch that everybody knew that these
games was gonna be running subpar
900p and everybody knew these things was
going to be running lower than 30 frames
per second now that doesn't excuse the
fact of the matter it's just the fact
that I will not accept anything less
when they do their next system
than what we have now we can't go
backwards what I like um tears of the
Kingdom to be on a more powerful system
absolutely I will still download it and
play it on my PC after I buy everything
for Zelda because I got a support I
gotta at least support it but Zelda's
one of those franchises that it doesn't
matter you're gonna buy it if you're
like a true fan of it you're gonna see a
completely different backdrop in this
room when Zelda comes out I got canvases
of zeld it's gonna be all over the place
of here but um yeah but you should hold
people accountable for the things that
they say if they say some stuff like red
Falls trash and why are you playing but
they turn around and want to play Tears
of the Kingdom at 15 frames per second
then yeah you got them but at least I'm
gonna tell you the truth
you got me I am 70 if if you're a fan of
something you you might be a little bit
lenient with certain things uh you might
Overlook certain things so I understand
what he's saying now I wouldn't accept
that now now for God of War I'm not
accepting that from from Sony oh so Sony
got a different standard of the
experience
at least it runs at least no you gotta
yeah Sony got a different system
their system their system says I should
be able to play what do you see Nintendo
out here saying that our system's online
with low NPCs do you see that
well it's probably not even online with
low people it's probably a lot yeah it's
now you're living on live with a
high-end phone
yeah I'm pretty sure my phone here might
be it's more powerful than a switch at
this point it's so sad though man all
right
all right so
here's the thing because uh we're
probably going to end this around the
time Dart goes me and Forte might chick
around and talk about the the Starfield
topic for a couple seconds but here's my
thing when it comes to it I don't think
Phil Spencer meant yo we're never going
to try to compete with with um
PlayStation I think Phil Spencer was on
some
look
we there is a lot of things we need to
improve and we're going to approve them
but uh
it when it comes to manufacturing
running
a console there's more to it than just a
publisher because a publisher they just
got to make good games and that's all a
console can have bad relations not
necessarily bad relations but it's
competition can have better relations
with something like scoring Unix and
that could [__] the games
uh there's more to it when you run a
console than just selling good games now
I would say in terms of like percentage
it's like I'd say 75 25. 75 if they came
out there and they had high quality
games every three months like they claim
that did well sure they might not appeal
to me but they do well
people would have a way more perspective
and uh perception on the Xbox brand
because these games are on it the
problem is we're not getting these games
the problem is we get stuff like redfall
that's extremely underwhelming to a vast
majority of people including myself and
I think that's the issue and and I wish
Phil would have because you could tell
Parents try to have them clear it up a
little bit but he got he ran out of time
I wish she would come out with a
statement on Twitter and clarify exactly
what he meant because I feel like the
statement could be deciphered multiple
different ways I think he was saying yo
people want to come out here and act
like this console war stuff where we
just got to make better games and we're
going to be PlayStation
that's not the case when you actually
run a platform if that was the case God
of War without so Call of Duty every
year without so Madden every year that's
not the case the majority of the games
that sell the most on every platform at
the end of every generation
all of its three is Multiplied all of it
for the most part that's the point I
made you know it's that casual box huh
except for Nintendo yeah seven Nintendo
right except for Nintendo because
they don't have yeah like they don't
have quality but look you're absolutely
right let me say this also when he said
that the Xbox one generation was the
worst generation to lose 100 agree 100
agree because we like we're all old
enough to know every generation it
starts over Phil mentioned that it
starts over I remember when the 316 PS3
started I know the PS3 they let you play
PS2 games initially but quickly that
stopped 360 I couldn't pay play original
Xbox games things like that this was the
first generation where you can play
every single previous generation game
seamlessly and the digital libraries
where he was last uh generation so the
Xbox one generation was the worst gen to
lose that's why guys are not about to
start over going to the Xbox Xbox
realizes they have to do things
differently right I saw somebody
mentioned on Twitter the Nintendo
GameCube was the last traditional
Nintendo console that was just as
powerful as the other two consoles they
realized they can't compete with power
with the Xbox and the PlayStation even
though the GameCube was technically more
powerful than the PS2 you know they had
them small ass little discs you know but
so Nintendo said we got to do something
different we have to do something
different yes Mario was great Zelda is
great but that did not move the needle
for the GameCube it just didn't it
didn't move the needle so they said
let's do something different
let's compete in a different way and
that Nintendo Wii
blew up it blew up so much that Xbox
tried you know had the connect and
Playstation had PlayStation Move
so Xbox realizes listen man
you can say is a defeatist attitude or
whatever it says this they realize that
you know what PlayStation 4 dominated
um a lot of people just made the simple
transition to the PS5 Xbox is probably
not going to be able to grab those guys
just by having a couple of great games
yes they're going to continue to make
great games they're going to make great
games I have to say of course redfo was
a stumble they're going to make great
games so they need to figure out how to
capitalize without you know out
counseling Nintendo and um
PlayStation and I think that's what Phil
was saying
yeah so uh you know what get you get
your last bars off uh dirt now you have
to get out of here you know anything
else you want to talk about when it
comes to the film give me some food too
while you're out yeah I might go to
Wingstop man no you gotta make a couple
runs
um no I mean that's pretty much it man I
I thought the interview
was a good interview like he was
transparent you can tell he was really
frustrated uh you know he was upset
about the rare fall situation and you
know what
um he well you know what this this
interview told me that Phil Spencer
definitely
listens he reads uh what's going on in
our community he already said he already
see the fire field stuff
I've been seeing that stuff too so that
obviously he's been seeing it and he
knows what he needs to do he mentioned
uh hellblade Force he said I've seen
these games I've seen them he's anxious
to show them these games to us and I
think you know and it's at the point
where it's coming but we'll see what
happens man I don't know if you guys
caught it because I know I only got dirt
for like another two minutes but uh kids
move mentioned something to me I didn't
notice it at the time but did you know
like the promotion for this E3 has a
valid and hellblade in it
no I didn't see that yeah well you know
it could be just us looking too much
into it but if you look at the picture
the Flames is that same flame oh yeah
yeah that's in a vowed and the the the
signal like the the sygia is at the like
the bottom left and bottom right is the
same ones that's in the hellblade
commercial well you know I can
definitely believe that a vile and
hellblade 2 will be at this year's
showcase absolutely those two games at
the end of the year I'm I'm I'm there
because
they put that March of next year they
put that that sound good for it they put
that hellblade commercial in that like
games that's coming out this year Phil
Spencer talked about in a recent term
like like it's going to come out soon
and I I I'm really starting to
especially with it in that showing case
now obviously we kind of expected it to
be there and it could be the beginning
of next year but to me that's one of the
biggest things that makes sense is that
game's gonna be there and and I think I
think the moment they didn't show it at
the game awards was the reason they
didn't show it there's because they
didn't want to have fatigue of showing
the game so I think they held that's the
last thing they're going to show yeah I
think that's yeah exactly so I think
they held it out of the Game of Wars
because the combat is the thing that
people want to see and they're going to
show an actual live gameplay demo during
the or probably not to get live gameplay
deal but a demo yeah play at the
Showcase and that's why I think it is
coming out this year during this holiday
yep hey yo hey can I say something right
quick before I leave I I agree with
everything you would have said but I see
slow-mo said it remains to be seen of
they can make a system seller like he's
talking about Xbox which is a great
point but at this point bro let's be
real or tell you know what are the
system sellers
art of Duty Maybe
yeah I always I always tell people that
next Generation doesn't start until Call
of Duty just as it does right now I
think Hogwarts Legacy moves a lot of
ps5s and was it February I really think
that it moves a lot of PS5 so
exclusives are huge I not now I do think
Spider-Man is a system seller it is um
so Xbox does need that system seller
again and I think they they will figure
out a way to have that or at least of
what like for them or the game pass so I
don't know but uh yeah I do want to say
that but sometimes the multi-platform
games can be system sellers also well
starfield's supposed to most of the time
the multi-plats are selling ways I do
think stockfield has a chance to be a
system seller for Xbox it's not should
it's it's not it should it should be I
think it has the extreme potential to be
a system seller I think Fable does I
don't know about microblade I don't know
yeah I don't know because you know the
name isn't out there yet but I
definitely believe like you guys are
watch star field fabled you know one
thing I know you're about to leave you
know one thing we don't talk about
that's going to be definitely a system
seller what's that Elder Scrolls 6. uh
people think the outrage was bad over
Starfield and some of these games not
coming to Playstation imagine when they
start picking up on like that game gets
in a development where they can start
showing it consistently and it only on
Xbox and everything like that Xbox and
PC obviously I think people don't
realize just that game hasn't really had
a presence since 2011 but there's a
reason it keeps coming back out because
it's extremely desired and wanted and
when this when the next iteration of
that franchise is only on one particular
platform it's going to push people to
the Xbox ecosystem there you go I agree
if you don't know what system sellers
are the PlayStation has one MPD for the
last four or five months in a row over
everybody Nintendo included guess what's
gonna happen
for some reason for some reason
Nintendo's gonna win and got it guess
what because they had a system seller
that came out even knowing a lot of
those people already have the system and
that's the funny thing about it
in the chat all right people where you
are man put it put your stuff in the
chat yeah I'll put it in um yo check out
my channel
good old dirt griggity
Pony free zone oh yeah don't don't go in
there if you're gonna go in there and
troll because there's no there's no
there's no second offense you out of
there
all right guys I I appreciate I gotta
get out of here all right see I put
everything in the chat thanks man so uh
this dude
hey bro this dude's coming after you
Forte he says five dollar super trap
Nintendo Donna theotaku Donna Taco's
coming after you he says I'm not Forte
Zelda was a seven out of 10 franchise
that was the same game reskinned before
breath of the wild not even in my top
five breath of the wild was so good it
became my favorite
I agree Zelda um Zelda was always in my
top five it just became my top three
once breath of the wild came out
all right let me uh let me get these
other super chats real quick
man you guys are really showing up I
appreciate man not even just the super
chats you know the likes the uh the
views I mean I'm having a rough week man
I've been having a rough week two dollar
Supertramp From gamer by choice uh Xbox
one said ecosystem seller uh seller
systems are a plus so I feel you on that
but I do think that the best way for
them to get them in the market is to
sell the console so that is still
probably one of their top priorities but
it's not on the very top both leaders
the two dollars subtract greatly
marketed third parties can be system
sellers yes Call of Duty is in there
every day he's doing very good uh so
let's let's get into the Starfield
conversation man Starfield what's what's
going on with you in Starfield man
what's going on with you in Starfield
uh same thing that's been going on with
everything Xbox and a holding pattern
waiting to see exactly how this is going
to play itself out I'm really it I'm not
really a big but there's the game like I
really I'm not really into the whole
medieval style type of game like how
Skyrim and stuff was I am more into the
Sci-Fi aspect that's why Starfield is
more of a a bigger interest to me so I'm
definitely want to give that a try just
because like people say Skyrim is space
and all this other stuff but I just like
the overall atmosphere of what they're
setting in it but
I'm I'm a realist and I have to be very
cautious of what's been going on do I
think starfield's gonna be good I do I
think it's going to be good but
as an Xbox fan I feel like it can't just
be good do you agree with the term that
uh you know Ryan McCaffrey said that he
feels like it's got to be a 10 out of
10. no yeah I think that's a little too
no because I know because I don't think
it start feels it's not starfield's
place
to basically save Xbox Xbox needs to
save itself by not only having a game
like Starfield come out but they need to
have more games like that that follow in
line and Concession that consistently be
that type of game Star feels just going
to be the eye of the storm because it's
going to be the next game on the list
and it is following up uh you know an
Abomination that was redfall in the way
that it came out so everybody's gonna be
looking at that game with those type of
uh with that type of lens but in my
opinion I feel like it's Microsoft and
Xbox's job to like kind of help star
field be everything it can be
but the only way they're going to do
that and get all the pressure off of it
is not let Starfield just be the only
thing we have it's like we have a lot of
other games get some type of uh
third-party deal or something that you
can talk about and announce it doesn't
have to be something that comes out this
year we just need to know what is Xbox
got for us in the future to get you more
excited you know what is like you said
we're going to probably see hellblade at
the Showcase we're going to see a vow
what are those things going to do like
once we see those games then a lot of
the pressure naturally will kind of fall
off of um Starfield just because people
are going to be even more excited about
the stuff they saw in the future but if
the if those games don't show well for
some reason like Microsoft has this
problem with like showcasing their games
and people not being really excited for
them after they see them then all the
pressure shows up on Starfield to be be
what they needed to be at that point but
it's Microsoft's job to basically get
everybody excited for the few future is
Starfield just needs to be one part of
that future not the whole thing that's
going to save Xbox you know so I
disagree with Brian McCaffrey yeah I
think Ryan's putting too much pressure
on starford now starfish got to come out
and it's got to be great but to like put
right put like 10 out of 10 positions on
it I think that's too much uh starford's
never going to be a perfect game in in a
way because I don't I don't think 10 out
of 10 is a perfect game I think 10 out
of 10 is the developer gave you the
quality of everything they meant to give
you everything in the game every
mechanic Works flawlessly there's no
real big issues I think that is where
you truly put a 10 out of 10. and to me
um I do think this game is going to be
good because Phil just being a little
extra with this would you not agree like
Phil is like look
I could tell you that I love Starfield
and I think you guys gonna love it but
at this point you want to hear from me
so I'm gonna let you get those in your
hand or those sticks in your hand and
you gonna tell me what that game's doing
right and that's and that's the that's
the way it should be when it comes to
just your excitement level wait until
you have it in your hands I mean it's
cool to have uh influencers and content
creators tell you about what they feel
about it but until you get that in your
hands and experience it that's when the
ultimate you know
um
surprise should happen for you at least
yeah and I think that's the thing like
you know
this isn't just on Starfield you know
starfield's got to come out it's got to
be a solid experience fun uh you know
it's got to be Innovative to to a degree
I don't think it's got to be like the
way that like Dustin was saying but I do
think it's God it's got to do things
differently and I think it is because
it's it's the first game that this
studio hasn't done that isn't Fallout or
Elder Scrolls in like 15 years they got
to
starfish got to come out and deliver
but they got to show you what the future
is Hellboy got to come out two three
months later and it's got to deliver to
a degree and then two or three months
four months after that a valve's got to
come out and it's got to deliver like
this isn't on one game starfield's gonna
sit the trend and start to give people a
little bit hope but it's going to take
the whole stable to fix that the issue
right slow-mo says I disagree Xbox put
this pressure on Starfield by releasing
a bad game like redfall
um until they have games that Gamers
feel they need to uh play that pressure
is going to be with every game they make
I agree with that but I know it's
disagreeing with that like I don't
disagree with that I just don't think
that it's starfield's place to be the
Messiah it's Xbox's place to make that
now he's absolutely right that like I
said earlier
starfield's going to have unnecessary
pressure on it due to what redfall did
but they could kind of alleviate
alleviate some of that pressure by
showing some of the stuff at this
showcase and letting those games
actually shine if they because you could
like we all look at these games and say
hey that looks really good and if we see
something that really Sparks your
interest and kind of takes your mind off
of well star feels the next big game
they got coming today you can start
thinking about what the future holds
instead of like well we gotta wait for
the next Xbox game to come out to see if
they actually deliver or anything like
that at least that way all the pressure
isn't just on Starfield because now you
have other games that you've seen that
you can dissect and analyze and say hey
I really like what they did here I like
what they did there and then with
Starfield comes out yes the expectation
is still going to be there but it won't
be all just in uncoming just falling
down on starfield's neck at that point
you know because Xbox showed a little
bit more that people should be more are
excited about outside of just that game
but that's up to Microsoft to do yeah
and we got to see if they do it we got
some super chats here we got a refine
our Super Chat from drawing TJ just
think the ABK Xbox has Starfield Halo
gears Forza Elder Scrolls and Diablo and
Call of Duty all system sellers I agree
uh you know getting the ABK is
definitely going to help them have quote
unquote system sellers but how many of
those it's just a seller how many of
those games are going to be exclusive I
don't think a lot you know uh gears is
definitely four is a definitely Elder
Scrolls most likely Diablo that's up in
the the field in Call of Duty they've
already said would be a multiplied if
they do buy the company so you know at
the end of the day they do need you know
these games on game pass but they also
need stuff to make their their ecosystem
and their consoles uh appeasing and that
does take making games exclusive now the
ABK dough is going to be good for Game
Pass
because it's going to give that service
a lot of value but in terms of selling
systems and selling the platform and
selling their services on the platform
uh you know they're gonna need exclusive
stuff that's only on their platform
they're just going to I don't know
that's why I felt like Sega was a better
one because you could literally have
bought Sega and made all that an
exclusive to your platform because I
don't think The Regulators would have
went at Sega like they're going at this
company we got a five dollar Super Chat
from David Lawrence
I think that's how you want me to
pronounce it I apologize if I messed
that up uh looking good Forte with the
weight loss lost 125 pounds myself keep
up the good work yeah man uh that's what
I'm working on too I'm trying to trying
to be healthier you know trying to get
that slender attic let's go yeah not yet
man I got I got a long way to go but I'm
gonna really start working on it so you
know
anything else you want to talk about
Forte we're going to get up out of here
because yeah let's look for everything
no you're good Mo basically just asked
what he said is Xbox putting pressure on
Starfield or do you think the community
is putting more pressure on starfish I
think the community's putting pressure
on starfa but I think Xbox is putting a
spotlight on Starfield there's a
difference yep and that is the
difference the spotlight doesn't need to
be there if Xbox go think about like
this
God of War
has a spotlight on it but you released a
game called Horizon forbidden West
earlier in the year
that had a spotlight too now that game
was a really now taking her leaving how
you feel about the story and how bland
and how uninterested a a Lloyd seems in
that game that game is a technical
Marvel when you look at it the decimal
engine is incredible
and as much as some people say that
game's boring you will never say that
that game isn't a good game it may not
be a game that you want to play because
you just don't like the way the story is
implemented in it but there's a lot of
people that really enjoyed that game so
God of War never got the pressure put on
it
that it would have got if hell what they
didn't come out earlier that year
because they had something to kind of
buffer and that's the thing I always
tell Gamers about the difference between
Xbox and Playstation people keep saying
well PlayStation hasn't had a game they
haven't even announced the game for this
year from their first party and it's
already six months in and I said you
know why people aren't complaining about
it yes gamer PlayStation Gamers want to
see what PlayStation has to offer
they're definitely getting anxious they
definitely want to see it but literally
not even seven months ago they got a
game called God of War
that was incredible that lasted with
them long enough to get them to the next
game so the last time that they took a
bite from the PlayStation Apple the game
they got was amazing and they're willing
to wait for the next thing whereas the
last thing that Microsoft released and
the things before that kind of been hit
or missed now Hi-Fi Rush is an anomaly
in that just because it was a stealth
drop but it wasn't the AAA game like God
of War was now it was still a good game
but we're talking about games that move
the needle to an extreme where you're
gonna you had the possibilities of
selling 10 15 20 million copies of a
game that's what Xbox needs to start
doing so that's why I always say listen
PlayStation gets away with stuff like
that is because the last game they
released was really really good and even
if you go back to the year of what 2021
after the PlayStation 4 came out people
was like oh well they have nothing for
the holiday well they did release
um they they release Ratchet and Clank
that year Spider-Man came out as a
release Game and they released return of
that year that was three games they
released and they didn't have nothing
for the fourth quarter but guess what
they did have they had exclusive titles
like ghost ghostwire Tokyo which was a a
game that they got from Xbox because of
the exclusivity deal and they also got
death loop at the end of the year so
those are first party titles but those
are games that was on their ecosystem
that you couldn't get anywhere else at
that point so that's kind of the
marriage you got to kind of understand
that PlayStation doesn't have to do what
Xbox is doing because PlayStation is
kind of doing things right on their own
we just want Xbox to get caught up to
doing stuff like that you know the
problem is like when you realistically
look at it is they spent too much time
on the 360 using other people's exams
using other people's games and then when
they started trying to self-correct
during the Xbox one uh Microsoft didn't
even know if they wanted to keep the
brand or not and when they close out
their Studios yeah when something like
that happens it's pretty much stopping
all progression like for probably six
months to a year nothing was going on in
Microsoft at all because they didn't
know what they wanted to do with the
brand but then when Phil Spencer
convinced them and showed them you know
what they can do and made uh Game Pass
more of what Microsoft's doing as of a
whole when it comes to like Microsoft
Office windows I think that showed them
that they can have this and it can and
it can actually be what Microsoft's
about and that's when it pushed it
forward and that's when they were
willing to open it up because Microsoft
will invest they will invest if they
feel like it actually can go somewhere
but at the end of the day it takes time
to build stuff now we got to see the
games red ball is not a good indication
I agree with you guys 100 redfall is not
a good indication but at the same time
I feel like Star filled and Hellboy
especially hellblade I think hellblade
in a valid is gonna be the most
important games for Microsoft for a lot
of reasons and one of the biggest
reasons is they were entirely funded by
Microsoft
I agree two dollars for that from David
loans pronounced Lions everyone does it
it's cool man I appreciate it say I knew
something was up I knew something live
ever watched hustle you never watched
hustles and bustle and Flow no no I
think I've seen it but it's it's hard to
tell if like I really paid it see you
know we ain't gonna go into that but
all right so
uh you know really row this back
where should people find you at man
what's going on
they can find me
um here on YouTube give me Forte
um
also on Twitter give me Forte uh DPS
podcast
um we rotate the channel we have a DPS
channel so if you don't know where the
channel is rotated at that week you can
always go to that channel and um
subscribe and watch it over there but uh
the homeboy Slumber back slap who's in
the chat right now he's going to be
moderating the channel on the show on
his channel this Thursday 9 P.M tomorrow
gonna be a great time gonna be talking
about all this stuff all over again
we're gonna really have to like get all
the IOP members to like do a collab with
you guys on your Channel
we yeah I think I think the only person
we had is you and and
Cog I'm gonna talk to I'm gonna talk to
all three of them and he's like yo let's
find a good week on a Thursday yeah it
will let's all yeah we could even do it
earlier in the day because I know some
people
um have other obligations yeah so we can
always move time it works like
constantly he's the only person that's a
wild card if he can make it or not
because it's always working yeah but
yeah whatever yeah like I said whatever
we always here to do anything with the
Lords we we love you guys and um it's
always great to be invited on platforms
like this because you guys
um you give everybody a chance to
basically you know shine and I really
appreciate that so
um whenever you guys are ready just let
us know and we'll definitely make it
happen but yeah check us out tomorrow
over there
um make sure you go sub The Slow Mo back
slaps Channel too he does amazing
content he's did a really good video on
Xbox recently talking about the things
that Xbox needs to do uh with their
platform and everything so let's check
that out too um put in the chat
both your uh all three uh the the DPS
YouTube channel uh put uh Fortes and
slow-mos probably Forte put yours so
they because I know all of them are
gonna look alike uh so yeah you got
yours and slo-mo put his
oh it's bland Drew what's up Blancher
you know what I miss you on wupperware
even though you know you you you said
some harsh things about me in private we
won't go too much into that I know we we
we we talk that through I ain't forgot
about that bland you I ain't forgot uh
but I do like your podcast when you do
it you know Blanchard's one of the most
gifted people in the community when it
comes to editing how the flow is of he
does it like he's very good on executing
videos
um but he just
sometimes man you got to make priorities
and I get it you know uh my my
priorities probably wasn't 100 where
they should have been it's probably why
my relationship fell apart but no yes so
I get it it's hard to really do that
sometimes you get too tunneled vision
and it hurt like hurts other aspects of
your life I'm gonna really improve on
that especially when it comes to like my
health there's a lot of things I really
need to go over but I'm pretty sure if
you come through here man you know it's
it's been a it's been a crazy week and I
think that's
is going to be good I you know I had up
to like 450 people in here you know hit
that like button Bland true it's the
least you could do is hit that like
button uh yeah I appreciate all you guys
for coming through uh it's it's been a
crazy week man it's been a crazy week
but
I have a light at the end of the tunnel
it's called Zelda on Friday
yes so talk with your chest yeah I'm
gonna distract myself hella much with
that game uh where do you think the the
Medicare score gonna be with that game
97 97 that is that's bold
97. that's bold I think they
I think they did if the if the if the
footage we saw of the dungeons is actual
Dungeons and they're substantial enough
and we we will get the reviews very soon
if there's substantial enough then yeah
97 because I think this game fixed all
the like a lot of people don't like the
um destruction when it comes to your
weapons and stuff
but I think they did enough tweaking to
that to make it more
digestible
people still don't want it
that's so good it gets a 10. like it's a
10. Well in order in order well in order
for it to get a 97 some people are going
to give it 10s I think a lot of people I
think I think IGN is going to give it a
10. again
I don't know I haven't talked to him in
about I've talked to people about like
the game itself but I haven't talked to
anyone about like when they Embark I
would assume tomorrow I would assume
tomorrow I think it's going to be midday
tomorrow probably probably you'll
probably wake up in the morning and see
a whole bunch of a whole bunch of
Articles of 10 out of 10. yeah I think
it's gonna be 97 overall though and
another thing I want to thank you guys
for like the love of my personal YouTube
channel like I'm seeing a lot of growth
on that and you know I'm putting a lot
of content I'm doing a video Monday
Tuesday Wednesday Thursday Friday uh
especially this week you know uh while
we're on Wednesday Monday and Tuesday's
videos was rough for me to get at
especially Mondays but I didn't want to
do Mondays only thing I want to do
Monday was sleep and I got myself out of
bed made sure you know I ate and I did
that video and you guys been showing up
you know and what's what people don't
realize about YouTube
is it makes it easier to grow on YouTube
when you have a base audience that
watches all your content because it
naturally puts you more into the
algorithm every week so I'm going to put
my YouTube channel in the chat uh so
definitely go there and sub to that if
you guys ain't sub to that I've been
making a lot of content guys I've been
putting in that work
okay Monday through Friday but and I
think I might have a video Sunday I
don't know yet
so it looks like let's see we got a
couple people saying so Superman says
breath of the wild was a 97 then we got
uh Metroid says it's going to be a 97.
clown said it's going to be a 101
um night wolf 95 Knicks 95 Texas 94 uh
mass produced 98 97 from slow-mo
um random citizen says 90 94 96 so yeah
the game's gonna be in the 90s is this
is going to be the high 90s or the mid
90s
you know it would be crazy if it comes
out of this at 88 88 89 well I doubt
that's the case I highly doubt that's
the case but like these days
Nintendo usually gets a blind eye for a
lot of things so I think they'll get a
pass but a lot of people are like oh you
didn't you you didn't do this
differently oh it's it's right an eight
out of ten nine out of ten it I I doubt
it the odds of that game being below 90
is probably like 10 but it Mr ordinary
says it's not just to be messy it would
be crazy if I got a 89.
it would that would that that would
shocked to be more than anything if we
got if it got that close to a 90 it
didn't hit that would be wow I'd be like
what happened
I'll be like looking at everybody's
reviews to see exactly why they gave it
not a 90. I would think that would be
more honestly to be for real even though
as much as I love the flame the
franchise I think that will bring more
Intrigue to the game it hitting 89 then
it being in the 97 because people would
want to know like well why did it only
get a night why did it even hit 90
I I think people will care even more if
it didn't
which is funny let me uh
okay someone in the I don't know if
you're listening uh but Imma do you a
solid and this is the only time I'm ever
gonna do this solid uh someone said I've
been I've been blocked off the IOP
Channel all right you know I'm not gonna
even look what you did all right all
right his name is Mike Johnson okay I'm
not gonna look what you did I'm gonna
give you the unblock this one time Mike
Johnson yeah y'all right there you're
right next to God of War 8585 and uh and
Jasmine orzo
so I'ma let you live I'ma let you
breathe you you are officially free but
if you get blocked in because I don't do
that I don't unblock people most of the
time my uh my mods are on point but I'm
I'm gonna go out and live and say they
got you wrong you had to listen to that
so I I'm gonna let you out of jail
you're out of jail but don't do it again
man because I ain't doing it again yeah
uh two dollar Super Chat this is your
one and only opportunity to stay out of
jail Randy G with the two dollar Super
Chat uh uh tears of the Kingdom will
score high because of the name uh yeah I
agree Zelda has a certain name in the
industry uh so I do think that it can
really pull off of that uh so you know
once again I want to appreciate it for
coming through like I said uh you know
you guys have been showing up heavy the
past couple weeks to this show and I
really appreciate that I think this is
the third fourth show in a row we've had
over 400 live viewers and you know uh we
keep doing it because you guys keep
showing up obviously if they're if there
was no audience I wouldn't keep doing
this and I appreciate everyone for
coming through here especially you know
the week I've had I've had a pretty uh
janky ass week too so it's nice to come
in here and just you know even if it is
for like an hour hour and 30 minutes
just to get my mind off of stuff it is
nice uh Donna talking with the uh
Nintendo don't talk with the five
dollars to chat if Ragnarok can keep a
95 and it was worse than the original in
a lot of ways tears of the Kingdom
better stay at least within one point yo
what happens if it gets below a Ragnarok
score ah nah man don't say that don't
say that yo this can't get to 89 We are
Never Gonna Hear the end of it it will
be
gonna be the one that's gonna lead the
charge
you're gonna be like I told you I I have
a feeling he would go he gonna be like
Nintendo can't handle he gonna be like
Nintendo can't handle Prosperity yeah I
I kind of disagree with him because I
saw him in the chat saying stuff about
um it shows that they can't do uh AAA
here's the thing I No One's Gonna excuse
redfall for the condition rightfall was
in but no I know a lot of stuff that's
behind the scenes
and it I'm telling you redfall it's not
that it was exception because they've
done that in the past
but there was extra ex
extreme circumstances that led to where
redfall was I agree it should have been
just canceled game should have just been
canceled if they weren't going to
actually pour money into it more money
into to delivering the the tide with the
developers envisioned from the start but
I don't think that that is a
representation of what Arcane can do I
think that's one of those games yo it's
been in the oven too long we got other
stuff we want people to do and we don't
think this game can be Savaged we're not
going to cancel it because we can get
some of that money back throw it out
there we're gonna go hide
uh and then when things are fine we're
gonna come back up that that's what I
see I get it at this point Microsoft has
done no
favors to anyone if you are on that
fence about Evers trusting them with the
support 100 understand you have every
right to do that Lord Metro with the two
dollar Super Chat Terrace of the Kingdom
ain't no 80 stop mixing alcohol look I
didn't say it was an 80. I would just
saying it would be funny if it was an
80. because I'm curious to see if it was
at 89. I'm curious to see like that's an
amazing score but if it was an eight see
there's certain games like Halo you
expect that to hit the 90s okay God of
War expect that to hit the 90s Tears
Don't hit at night one of those games
you expect in the 90s I don't think very
few games very few Zelda games have have
missed the 90s yeah I'll be shocked if
that don't hit a 90. that I'll tell you
that's why I say it'll be more interest
in in uh in it if it didn't hit 90 did
it hit 97. all right so people expect
that
once again though I appreciate everyone
coming through here you know hit that
like button on your way out I'm assuming
yeah thanks to Forte and uh and Dirk for
coming through I was gonna do the show
alone and I was sitting there like an
hour before the show because dirt didn't
know if he could make us he got uh
personal stuff going on I'm like I'm
gonna see if Forte's busy because
sometimes he can do stuff on the
Wednesday sometimes he can't but you
know I'm gonna send you guys over there
to fame entertainment on the level one
podcast go in there and tell them the
attic show sent you man and uh you know
I appreciate everyone coming through
again really you guys have no idea how
much it meant to me and until next time
next week this is Lord addict and
gaming14 we out here